[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein menü und zwar in der
hüfte zu bereiten mit aroma tomaten und
der moral ist noch nicht da aber er
kommt gleich nach hause denn erholt
samira vom ballett ab oder freute sich
schon richtig drauf bei der rinderhüfte
ist es so ihr könnt die am stück kaufen
oder auch schon fertig geschnitten
nur das problem ist wenn sie schon
geschnitten wird die top-chance leider
falsch geschnitten wird da die fasern
einfach in zwei verschiedene richtungen
gehen und ich zeig euch jetzt heute wie
man das richtig macht zeigt jetzt aber
erstmal die zutaten
ich brauche dafür 600 gramm
cocktailtomaten zwei chilis etwa acht
bis zehn esslöffel olivenöl 2 esslöffel
honig eine unbehandelte orange typen
jahren und eine ganze rinderhüfte ich
werde zuerst einmal bevor ich mich ins
fleisch kümmere um die beilagen kümmern
daher nehme ich eine auflaufform und
gebt da die tomaten rhein und die lassen
mich lasse ich jetzt noch am grünen dran
nämlich die zweite ist und wer die fein
hacken die müsst ihr natürlich nicht
nehmen aber ich mag chili ganz gerne
[Musik]
und darüber gebe ich jetzt honig
lesen kommt auch hinterzogen
darunter ganze thymian den einfach so
ein bisschen zurecht schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich sie orange da kommt der
schale mit rein und ich habe heute
gelernt dass man die drei besuchen nimmt
und nicht so rum wenn zu bringen fiel so
viel kraft auf und treibt den weißen dem
bitteren teil betreiben
[Musik]
ein bisschen orangensaft presse ich auch
noch dazu
die orange ich jetzt klein die passt
auch in die zitrus presse
und jetzt noch mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
[Musik]
hmm
und die tomaten werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 185 grad
umluft etwa 20 minuten gebacken
wenn sie auf platten sind super 6 und in
dieser zwischenzeit kann ich blitz
fleisch genommen jetzt kommen wir zum
wichtigsten part und zwar geht es jetzt
um die rinderhüfte und da ist es so wie
gesagt könnt ihr sie schon
vorgeschnitten kaufen oder einfach
selber zu schneiden beim selber zu
schneiden habt ihr den vorteil dass er
sie richtig schneidet wenn ihr die
rinder hafte für euch hinlegt dann seht
ihr dass die fasern in zwei verschiedene
richtungen verlaufen
und zwar hier auf der auf meiner linken
seite auf eurer rechten seite einmal in
die richtung und hier auf meiner rechten
seite einmal in diese richtung das heißt
wenn ich jetzt das messer nehmen würde
und gegen die phase einfach so schneiden
wollen würde wird es hier jetzt richtig
sein aber hier war es ebenfalls
hier müsste ich so schneiden das heißt
ich musste jetzt verteilen jetzt nehmt
ihr euch ein scharfes messer und könnt
ihr in der mitte das deck auseinander
schneiden
[Musik]
hier in der mitte stößt sie jetzt auf
eine sehne ich öffne das jetzt mal damit
er es kurz sehen könnt und da müsst ihr
jetzt links und rechts mit dem messer
dran vorbei schneiden
[Musik]
hab ich die seele wie entfernt die müsst
ihr nicht wegschmeißen
die könnt ihr zum beispiel benutzen um
eine suppe zu kochen oder ohne soße zu
koch und fleischer ganz viel geschmack
mit dabei lege ich das eine stück mal
zur seite und zeigt euch jetzt hier wie
man jetzt gegen die faser schneidet
damit ich jetzt kleine sticks schneiden
kann weil ich jetzt hier einmal
halbieren
[Musik]
nimmt das stück so ein bisschen zusammen
mit kann ich daraus drei steaks
schneiden das heißt ich schneide jetzt
hier außen das zweck nämlich auch in der
suppe oder für gulasch zum beispiel
[Musik]
und jetzt schleunigst in drei teile
hier oben schneide ich jetzt die spitze
weg und auch hier unten der spitze weg
jetzt kann ich hier raus auch zwei
steaks zu beraten und bei dem hilft
städtische so wenn es richtig zubereitet
wird ein richtig geschnitten wir dann
ist wirklich so zart wie rinderfilet im
sport eben ganz viel geld
[Musik]
hier bereits meiner alten pfanne erhitzt
die eignet sich am besten um stacks
anzubraten habe ich jetzt ein bisschen
butter schmalz drin und musste hierzu
ein bisschen reduzieren und werde jetzt
mach ich schon ganz heiß und werde jetzt
von beiden seiten ganz scharf angreifen
[Musik]
wenn sie von beiden seiten angebraten
sind nämlich sie heraus auf eine platte
die auch für den backofen geeignet ist
[Musik]
also dass ich die samira die heimteams
ich habe die stacks angebraten und habe
sie jetzt noch nicht gewürzes mache ich
erst danach kurz vor dem servieren
und ich möchte dass die stakes medium
werden und geht es jetzt in den backofen
bei 90 grad als ich hab jetzt die
tomaten oben noch drin hab den einfach
runter gestellt und da werde ich dann
die kerntemperatur von etwa 56 bis 58
erreichen
und da kommen sie jetzt etwa fünf bis
zehn minuten rein
[Musik]
richtig gut oder ich habe hier noch in
fast sechs übrig die werde ich zeit
nicht alle braten
denn so viele leute sind mir gar nicht
deswegen gebe ich jetzt hier in einen
beutel umwelt evakuieren
hey cool durch die glatten sluiter
gebaut aus der verpackung was weil die
geniale sind möchte ich stolz auf dich
hab dir richtig toll abgibt bei dem
kamera jungs ja ich werde jetzt ein
wacom ihren damit ich sie einfach länger
haltbar machen kann
die kann man jetzt so im kühlschrank
dann noch ein paar tage aufheben oder
können sie auch ganz gut einfrieren und
der vorteil vom 1 april ist dass ich
kein gefrierbrand bildet und ist einfach
schön
da geht die ganze luft raus jetzt habe
ich hier das fleisch drin da muss man
eben darauf achten dass die beutel
einfach eine gute qualität haben dass
sie ohne weichmacher sind hier gibt es
also einen clip setzt man das hier dran
und kann den beuteln verschließen
ok jetzt habe ich hier aber noch die
luft drin
es macht trotzdem offen aus erneut
setzte das hier auf den blauen punkt und
jetzt musst du hier so bis zu pumpen
ziehen und drücken
ein bisschen schneller
jetzt sieht man wird das fleisch richtig
schön eingeschweißt ist und die ganze
luft weg ist das wirklich eingefahren
das beste fleisch werde ich jetzt hier
auch ein vakuum ihren und ihr könnt so
zum beispiel auch sowie edgar machen das
mache ich jetzt zwei hier jetzt nicht
aber das nächste mal werde ich auch das
so wieder machen habe ich auch schon ein
video dazu gemacht und da könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch ganz viele verschiedene
kräuter und aromen mit rein geben und es
mit ein vakuum ihren du darfst machen
und während die sanierer hier noch die
luft raus geht werde ich nach dem steaks
schauen und werten fleisch thermometer
benutzen und es zeige ich euch mal kurz
das gleich thermometer ist digital vom
militär angewandt und jetzt steckt hier
am besten
seitlich ein passiert was dann von oben
mit und etwa bis zur mitte
bei mir sind es etwa 23 grad das heißt
ich dass sie noch ein paar minuten drin
[Musik]
und darf ich sie mir okay jetzt kann ich
servieren und kurz vor dem servieren
werden die stakes noch mal ganz kurz
angebraten
jetzt sind sie nämlich lauwarm und sowie
sami okay ich kann jetzt hier schon mal
die tomaten anrichten
die gebe ich jetzt so oft den teller ja
nach das netz stammt von mir und die
besten steaks ideen für die ja und da
kriegt man einfach so diese großes
schicht aus ihnen werden bisschen spaß
muss die pfanne note 1 rennen an
leitungsgremium
[Musik]
jetzt nimmt er hier von diesem so gibt
es hier auch noch mal etwas
das ist richtig lag salz und pfeffer
komme ich mag sein es macht du machst du
treffer nee ich mach das asiatisch
großer komik kleine kamera sondern und
die anderen stacks die werde ich jetzt
gleich kurz vor dem servieren dann
antraten
ok sieht sehr über sich aus ich schweiz
war ein richtig schöner miete werde das
erstmal zeigen kann wie es irgendwen
aussieht leider haben wir keine
steakmesser doch hinten aber so jetzt
schau mal rein
tschuldigung ammann moratorium eine
schöne flasche natürlich damals zeigen
also wenn man es natürlich nicht sein
medium es muss natürlich länger aus also
ich mag es so ihr könnt natürlich
richtig durch machen das ist eure sache
jeder max anders mein fleisch wirklich
medium da haben die gar tabelle aber
auch auf meine locken können da
eigentlich die temperatur anschauen und
könnt dann eben schon was für euch das
richtig ist und wie gesagt ich probierte
und sanierer film den papa und super bei
den tomaten kam es so zu machen
seine gabe und dann können dass sie hier
oben anfassen und dann hier mit der
gabel einfach die tomaten rausziehen es
schon die schale
[Musik]
thomas schaaf mit dem honig ist es
vielleicht richtig als wüsstest du dich
sagen das ist ein fehler und so sieht
man eben dass man wirklich richtig viel
geld sparen kann wenn man das oft
fleisch also das höchste gericht ich
zerlegt und falls ihr das rezept gerne
nachmachen wohlstand geht auf sallys -
blog.de steht noch mal ganz genau und
ich denke das war sehr informatives
video oder und als hauptpreis ist es
wirklich super geeignet und tomaten
ich habe nie freien klasse finde ich
auch sehr gut
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und guten
appetit und jetzt setzen wir uns auch
zum essen
[Musik]
können wir das ist man eigentlich meinen
neue westen gewesen
hast du jetzt ernsthaft unter trockener
geschmissen hat richtig sortieren
dann tut mir leid ich schmeiße einfach
rein das gehört zusammen ihrer jetzt
schon meister kann sich beim papa
bedanken
sie soll ihrer schule hatte schöne neue
kleider und der papa holt mir eine neue
westen ist zu groß
kein problem
[Musik]